you did a film in Mexico this must have
been ten years ago Rubio Accorsi yeah we
the guy editor yeah yeah you know what's
interesting it's one of those things
that shows you there was we found two
versions of the poster there's the
version of the poster that was shown in
Mexico let's show that okay and there
you are on the left grabbing your
package as one does and this is the one
that they put out in the United States
your hand is kind of pushed to the side
and you're pointing and it was curious
too he said it yes was that a sensor
that jumped in immediately definitely
this is not a joke no Photoshop this is
what happened basically they said no in
the states you cannot be in the cinema
grabbing your bolts and I golike and
what happens to Americans when you know
your balls get itchy yeah do you cross
the border to Tijuana scratch
I love that image I'll be right back
[Music]
what were the EU's frontier both that's
why I have this - okay that's what every
now and then you'll notice andy sneaks
over here for a second this sneaks back
this is where we take care of business
right here
you